[Music]
what are
everyone's uh christmas plans this year
because it's an interesting year to say
the least dude i'm kind of waiting to
hear the
like what what we're gonna do what is
appropriate well no like i'm here
wouldn't here what the family feels
comfortable doing
oh okay you're a family so i'm down for
whatever but i need to hear what they're
doing
i got some geezers in my family that are
paranoid so i was like i'm gonna come
over
and then be by the window and touch them
like that
like a jail like a jail guy what about
you guys
well so we're selling our house so we
haven't even talked about this but i'm
like
should we get a christmas tree or no
because we have a christmas tree
we do like a real one you think we have
a real christmas tree for like a full
year
i don't know oh she told you you guys
put it in a box you put your
she's like yes we have a real christmas
tree it's in a box yeah it's in the
garage if you guys
want a christmas tree there's one at the
office thank you oh yeah i saw it
i went there to clean up clean up my
office what are you doing tara
i don't know i think i might go back
home to kansas for a couple days but
i would really love to actually take a
vacation but i it sounds like we're not
able to go to most places you can go to
hawaii you want to go to a tropical
place
hawaii is allowed it's open are you like
they just opened a couple weeks ago you
have to watch it though because new york
just shot down to california residents
yesterday are we that bad so if if new
york is i mean i think other people
florida might be better but who knows
what will happen over the next month or
two months it's like you can plan but
you can't
really plan for anything you really
can't plan i bought tickets to a joe
rogan dave chappelle show
um back like last year and then it went
from april
and until like a june july show to
september and then they finally canceled
and refunded it all because they're like
we just keep leading everyone on but
it's also because they don't know what's
happening so
you just can't really plan anything
that's crazy yeah and
for christmas like uh there seems like a
lot of people don't know what's
happening
uh in terms of how to celebrate and be
with family
and also the world the the in the world
of santa claus
uh industry uh where people dress up the
santa clauses
doesn't seem like there's a whole lot of
work for them either and they're
actually going virtual now
a lot of plans to go virtually oh but
they're actually gonna freeze
sam are you there yeah hello i see santa
like every month
because um where he really lives is
santa's village in arrowhead and um i
have a
annual pass to the santa's village
because there's a bike park there
so every month i go and then he's there
with mrs claus and all that in the
middle of summer too he was there
sweating his ass off waving to everybody
yeah he's there all the time yeah wait
what
that's [ __ ] up i know he should be in
the older abusers yes
he should be in the north pole but
that's where he really lives so
santa ana that's his picture does he
wear shorts
yeah he has santa shorts he has santa
shorts with the overalls
and like yeah he's there and singing to
the kids and stuff
that's good yeah so he's not as festive
as we would like to think this has been
your santa update everybody
i'm just saying santa's alive and well
guys like
and he's not in the north pole he's
actually american and he lives in
lake arrowhead who's he voting for
[Laughter]
well that town i think is pretty
pro-trump so i don't know
santa's pro-trump yeah i did not know
that i don't know like hero had santa
yeah well is your santa uh in the
fraternal order of real bearded santas
because that's a real organization wow
and they're about 60 650 members strong
when i was a kid if you had a real beard
and you were dressed as santa you were
the real santa
fair enough any color beard no the white
beard of course you gotta have a white
beard
yeah but it's crazy to think that those
santas are dead now
that's so sad what the [ __ ] yeah because
i was a little like a lifespan of uh
of the santa age yeah
i guess it is a it's a shorter amount of
time
i could see i don't believe you
uh you know what that's a great question
so yeah so santa clauses are typically
older people
and you would think that there's a
there's a bigger learning curve
to get on zoom and so but i would assume
that whoever's hiring them
i think whoever's hiring them is you're
probably going to train them right now
how are kids going to take the
senate pictures now like are they just
going to prop the [ __ ] yeah like the
prop the laptop and then they're gonna
just sit
like with santa like here yeah or maybe
yeah it's like the the squares just like
there's santa and then there's like you
and that square because you're
facetiming with them
i don't i don't know i don't know it's
like that ticklish it's really more
about the
interaction though it's more about like
talking to santa and santa's like
what do you want for christmas did you
guys do the meet and greets at the mall
when you were kids oh yeah yeah yeah i
did yeah i made my parents wait in line
for hours for that
you were those kids huh yeah and all
that's being canceled by the way the
mall stuff yeah
it's it's most of it's the mall's even
open right now uh they are
some places they're they're like a ghost
town though like outdoor malls right
there
no you can go inside dude pre-covered
multiple ghost town bro
true [ __ ] sake it was that calm
a place to go a walk power walk for
for like older people i feel like with
ac that's what you see now
yeah that's the laziest walking i've
ever heard of
we got to get our steps in we're going
to the mall wow
but yeah so back to this fraternal order
of real bearded santas they were
recently
extremely disappointed whenever a
a certain government campaign to help
spread the uh coronavirus uh vaccine
word of the coronavirus vaccine got shut
down
so apparently a guy named michael caputo
he is a
former assistant secretary secretary of
the department
of health and human services health and
human services thank you
and uh he was talking to this uh to the
chairman of fraternal order real beard
santas
uh to create a campaign to help spread
awareness for the vaccine
and uh if they were on board that all
santa's
uh standard performers would get the
first uh an early access to the vaccine
themselves
yeah so a lot of the the workers the
santa clauses were actually very happy
about that
but then something happened and it got
cancelled
and then i was actually asking you
earlier if you knew anything about
michael caputo because you were
you are our uh his name our
correspondent for uh all things
political all i know
is that they are not as close to the
vaccine as they thought and so that's
probably what happened
there yes yes a lot of things to iron
out
absolutely would you guys take it if it
came out not the first one
i said i would a couple weeks ago and
now i'm not so sure because i heard
something i would take it if they allow
me to travel everywhere invincibly
like invincibly like meaning like if i
if i
if i have like a tag that says i took
the vaccine right now i can travel the
world
i would take it even if it gave me a
third leg okay
i don't i don't know if i want to take
it because every flu vaccine i take
that's when i get the flu but i need to
travel and get some [ __ ] and the years
i don't take it i don't get the flu
he has to travel for [ __ ] don't you
understand do you hear the man my [ __ ]
is at home so i don't really need that
good man come on just mine
goddamn
[Laughter]
[Music]
you guys are not thinking you guys are
only thinking about yourselves and your
married lives you're not thinking about
the single guys
out there or the single people in the
world that need to get out of the house
and get out of quarantine
hey dude nobody should try to get you
laid more than me my friend and you know
that for me i know thank you
i appreciate it i know thank you
i hate quarantine yeah so wait so what
did you hear about the the
vaccine by the way like what so you
weeks ago we talked about this on jk
everyone was asked would you take the
vaccine i said yes because my father has
a pre-existing condition i haven't seen
him in a year
you want to hug him i went home and i
was checking out some of the stuff about
the vaccine
and i saw that polling said many people
didn't want to take their vaccine and i
was like what's behind that
and yeah there's they're just having
some issues with the finalization of it
and i don't know if i would take it in
the first round
i see it takes a while to know what the
long-term
ramifications could be of of those
things normally you have like five ten
years
you have a double-blind study you have a
bunch of different things they do they
didn't get to really necessarily
do a lot of research on that so i get it
now does it does it have
the same type of like things that can go
wrong
like if you take some stomach medicine
and then you have suicidal thoughts or
something so even bill gates was
interviewed about this recently and he
basically
said because he was confronted about the
fact that many people who have
who have been tested for the vaccine
they've had they've had complications
and he was just saying that you know
hopefully they'll get it worked out so
bill gates yeah bill gates what's his
involvement in this whole thing he's one
of the financiers of it
oh but that's why he's they're saying
there's a conspiracy
of him 5g so i put like microchips in
everyone yeah just some kind of crazy
[ __ ] yeah
i don't care man just give it to me if i
can travel you get the [ __ ]
any means necessary would you catch
would you catch
coronavirus i would have because i have
the [ __ ] food okay let me ask you
this
if the chick doesn't have the i got the
covet vaccine you don't give a [ __ ]
right
no she has to have it oh [ __ ] and that
diminishes your chances
of what getting more [ __ ] so it's like
no i'll inject her when i see her
oh you can't just give out two like that
what you will inject her will he'll
eject her and then he'll inject it
okay so in my perfect world right like
okay i just i just did that [ __ ] thing
as a joke
right what the [ __ ] just blew off your
head i just i'm tired of just staying
home
well i'm actually not home all the time
yeah but i i'm just tired of
being restrained right i want to travel
and if this vaccine
can make me go like oh well americans
can't come in
except for the people who who took the
bag it's like why
why not i mean what are the side effects
is it really bad your dick falls off
okay never get everyone's face i could
forget everyone's face
there's a lot of ugly people including
me your tongue falls off too
i need that for the food oh they both
fall off for the food
for the food taran would you take it um
not the first round yeah i'm actually
more worried about it
yeah i'd rather just be conscientious
and then and then wait until the second
you're not an early adopter
not in this world no i'm good too i'm
ahead of the trend
yeah i think honestly i think the best
we can do
we've already been doing you know we're
in the mass socially distancing
understanding the etiquette about that
and thoughtful and being yeah being
mindful and thoughtful and i think
what else what else are you gonna do you
can't shut down everything forever and
be afraid of everything forever you know
how is taiwan doing it because i just
was like i was online and i just came
across they're amazing
contact tracing i didn't even i didn't
even read the article but the headline
was like
um they beat in 30 days yeah like
taiwan's just kicking ass
contact tracing yeah what is that
they've got everybody's they know they
know exactly
they're tracing all the phones so they
know when someone has it
where they've been who they've been in
contact with they can do all that
through technology but we we don't allow
that level of monitoring here because it
doesn't fit our american values
don't spy on me okay thank you
in terms of managing a pandemic it's
been very successful i don't mind if
they spy
if it's for like you know disease but
don't look at my dick pics
yeah don't check his dick don't do that
that's infringing on my privacy
on your privates
[Music]
foreign